je vous propose de commencer en vous
remerciant d'être présent soit en
présentiel soit aussi en distanciel
puisque je crois que vous êtes un
certain nombre à être derrière vos
écrans j'espère que vous nous entendez
bien ceux qui sont derrière vos écrans
n'hésitez pas à vous manifester si il y
a le moindre problème technique je
remercie et salut la présence de Jean
Raymond Hugonnet qui est vous le savez
le rapporteur pour avis au nom de la
commission de la culture de l'éducation
et de la communication des crédits de
l'audiovisuel et avec lequel je
travaille très étroitement depuis de
nombreuses années et je le remercie
d'être là ce matin pour partager avec
moi un certain nombre de réflexions que
nous menons depuis maintenant plusieurs
mois et qui a abouti à la proposition de
loi que j'ai donc déposé et qui est
l'objet de notre conférence des presses
de ce matin proposition de loi
sur la réforme de l'audiovisuel public
et la souveraineté audiovisuelle si vous
me permettez je vais dire quelques mots
pour vous décrire un peu le à la fois le
contexte mais aussi le contenu de cette
PPL et puis après bien sûr je répondrais
et nous répondrons à vos questions si
vous en avez mais je ne doute pas que
vous en aurez alors quelques éléments de
contexte sur cette PPL avant de rentrer
dans le fond de ce document d'abord mais
ce n'est pas à vous que je vais
l'expliquer le secteur de l'audiovisuel
connaît de profonde mutation depuis
maintenant plusieurs années mutations
liées bien sûr à l'offre de programme
qui s'est diversifié avec l'apparition
des plateformes qui a créé une vraie
concurrence par rapport aux acteurs
français
mutation qui sont liées bien sûr aussi
au développement des des réseaux sociaux
et le fait que l'accès à l'information
ne se plus uniquement à partir de de la
télévision ou de la radio mais qu'elle
est très diversifiée et de fiabilité
plus ou moins avérées et puis d'autres
évolutions qui voient le jour et qui
nous font penser que la révolution des
technologies et la révolution des usages
n'est pas terminée elle est encore en
cours dans les évolutions en cours ou à
venir je voudrais en citer que
quelques-unes qui probablement ne sera
pas exhaustive du coup mais d'abord la
télévision numérique connectée pardon la
télévision connectée qui fait que le
cadre très franco-français de la TNT
contrôlée par l'Autorité de régulation
et remise en cause et qu'aujourd'hui un
certain nombre d'experts s'interrogent
sur la pérennité du système de TNT et de
aussi de comment
préserver l'accès aux chaînes
françaises dans le système de télévision
connectée je reviendrai deuxième
évolution
qui est également en cours elle concerne
les droits de retransmission sur les
événements sportifs on l'a constaté
maintenant depuis quelques mois et on le
verra encore plus je pense d'ici
quelques mois vous avez une explosion
des prix des droits de transmission des
événements sportifs qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui des acteurs
essentiellement les plateformes
américaines arrivent sur le marché avec
une puissance financière qui est
incommensurable incomparable par rapport
à celle de nos acteurs français et qui
remet en question le fait que des sports
les événements sportifs qui par
définition sont des événements
populaires puissent être accessible
partout sur les chaînes en linéaire et
puis dernière évolution qui est en cours
sur lequel je voudrais juste dire un mot
mais on perçoit bien qu'elle peut avoir
de profonde impacts ou de profonds
impacts aussi sur notre système
audiovisuel c'est la question de
l'intelligence artificielle qui va venir
aussi percuter nos usages et nos
technologies par rapport à ces
évolutions la puissance publique et
notamment l'état a du mal à réagir
s'interrogeant de manière très régulière
sur est-ce qu'il faut encadrer ou au
contraire est-ce qu'il faut laisser
faire et voir jusqu'où vont ces
évolutions
d'usage et ses évolutions technologiques
et finalement nous sommes restés sur le
cadre de la loi de 86 86 il y a 37 ans
une époque où les
internet n'existaient pas les
plateformes n'existaient pas alors
certes cette loi de 86 a depuis été
modifiée pour tenir compte d'un certain
nombre de solutions mais le cadre
général reste celui-là et le fait que la
loi de 86 demeure et je pense que dans
la haute 86 il y a des principes qui
sont fondamentaux qu'il faut bien sûr
préserver respecter mais la loi de 86
impose aux acteurs français des des
règles des contraintes qui ne sont pas
imposées aux acteurs étrangers en
particulier aux plateformes et cette
distorsion crée une asymétrie de
concurrence qui aujourd'hui est un
élément de fragilité et qui nous paraît
un aliment de fragilité majeur pour les
acteurs français qu'ils soient public ou
qu'ils soient privés d'où l'objet de
cette pppl qui est clairement
une proposition de loi pour
assurer notre souveraineté audiovisuelle
et lutter autant qu'on peut le faire
d'un moyen législatif sur les asymétries
de concurrence pour lequel l'ensemble
des acteurs encore une fois qu'il soit
privé ou publics sont actuellement
fragilisés et nous ont alerté à de
nombreuses reprises pour nous dire
attention il y a danger si nous ne
sommes pas davantage protégés dans un
système qui est devenu très
concurrentiel
dernier élément de contexte
il ne vous a pas échappé que nous sommes
un certain nombre à réfléchir à
l'audiovisuel bien sûr ici au Sénat et
depuis de nombreuses années puisque nos
prédécesseurs Jean Raymond et à moi je
pensais par exemple à André gatelin et
Jean-Pierre Leleu avait sorti un rapport
de référence en 2015 plus récemment Jean
Raymond wegonnet avec Roger caoutchi
l'année dernière on sortait un autre
rapport sur
l'audiovisuel public et puis il y a
aussi nos collègues de l'Assemblée
nationale qui ont lancé il y a
maintenant plusieurs mois une mission
d'information qui est présidée par
Jean-Jacques Gauthier dans le rapporteur
et Quentin bataillon qui travaille sur
les missions de service public les
démarches ne sont pas concurrentes au
contraire elles sont complémentaires et
c'est bien dans cet esprit que nous les
avons que nous l'avons que nous avons
travaillé et que je vous propose le
matin cette que je vous présente cette
matin cette cette proposition de de loi
nous savons bien qu'il y a une période
politique que nouvelle qui s'est ouverte
depuis les élections législatives et qui
impose si on veut avancer sur des
documents législatifs de co-construire
les textes ensemble
l'Assemblée nationale avec nos collègues
députés réfléchissent sur les missions
du service public nous nous avançons sur
les questions d'asymétrie et
d'organisation de l'audiovisuel public
nous savons également
que la réforme de des finances de
l'audiovisuel public avec la suppression
de la contribution à l'audiovisuel
public il y a un peu moins d'un an
maintenant n'est pas achevé puisque pour
pérenniser le système de financement
c'est-à-dire la fraction de TVA affectée
à l'audiovisuel public il faudra
modifier la loi de la LOLF la loi de sur
les lois de finances que c'est une loi
organique et que une modification
d'Adolphe nécessite un accord
l'Assemblée nationale mais aussi du
Sénat il y a donc un dialogue qui va
s'ouvrir dans les semaines et les mois à
venir j'ai un peu commencé mais qui va
s'ouvrir sur cette réforme de
l'audiovisuel public en déposant cette
PPL
la majorité sénatoriale apporte la
première pierre à l'édifice que nous
devons construire ensemble et bien sûr
c'est à travers les échanges que nous
aurons que cette réforme se fera mais en
tout cas la position du Sénat et la
majorité sénatoriale à travers cette PPL
et désormais posé alors quelques mots
sur le sur le contenu de la proposition
de loi cette proposition de loi est
construite autour de deux chapitres l'un
concerne l'audiovisuel public le second
chapitre concerne les questions
d'asymétrie dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure je vais essayer de les résumer
sommairement et puis bien sûr je
répondrai à nous répondrons à vos à vos
questions
pour entrer peut-être plus dans le
détail sur le contenu des différents
articles alors le premier chapitre qui
est composé d'une
[Musique]
d'une dizaine d'articles de 9 exactement
traite de l'audiovisuel public et
prévoit la création d'un holding
réunissant France Télévisions Radio
France Lina et France mediamonde holding
et dans notre proposition de loi
qualifiée de France média appelé France
média
est comporte donc les quatre filiales
détenus à 100% par l'État avec une mise
en place au 1er janvier 2024 de cette
holding
je vais pas vous décrire il y a 9
articles qui décrit cette cette holding
et qui ajuste les textes législatifs les
articles les articles de loi nécessaire
pour permettre cette holding il y a bien
sûr
un article sur la composition du conseil
d'administration avec deux représentants
des chambres à représentant de de
l'Assemblée nationale à représentant du
Sénat des commissions Haddock celle de
la culture de l'éducation et de la
communication trois représentants
désignés par l'état de personnes
qualifiées désignés par l'arcome et deux
autres personnes désignées par le
conseil d'administration
sur avec un avis conforme de l'arcom et
enfin je n'oublie pas de représentants
du personnel le président de cette
holding et désignée par un
sur proposition du conseil
d'administration de la société et
désignée en par un décret en conseil de
ministres après avis conforme de
l'arcome et après aussi à vie au titre
de l'article 13 de la constitution des
deux assemblées
[Musique]
sur cette question de la holding je
pense que nous aurons l'occasion d'y
revenir à travers vos questions mais
quelques éléments
d'information d'abord nous nous sommes
persuadés
que la
direction à suivre et est un
rapprochement déstructures nous l'avons
dit à de nombreuses reprises je sais
référence au rapport de 2015 André
gatelin et Jean-Pierre Leleu qui déjà
parlé de la création de la holding plus
récemment de la du rapport fait par Jean
Raymond Gonnet et Roger karucci qui
allait plus loin vers la fusion nous
remarquons que cette la nécessité de
faire converger les structures et à peu
près partagé partout y compris par
l'État puisque si on regarde le comme
qui s'achève ou le comme à venir l'un
comme l'autre ont mis comme axe
prioritaire de faire travailler ensemble
les différentes structures de
l'audiovisé public toute la question qui
se pose et à quel rythme et comment
à travers cette PPL nous disons
clairement qu'il faut aller au-delà des
codes que les comme ne peuvent pas être
l'outil unique ce n'est pas d'ailleurs
un outil de gouvernance que c'est un
outil de lien
essentiellement budgétaire un peu
stratégique entre l'État et les
différentes entités de duel de
l'audiovisuel public mais qu'on ne peut
baser une stratégie uniquement à partir
des comes dont on connaît la fragilité
juridique certes elle a été le dernier
comme ont été respectés mais ça n'a pas
été le cas des précédents comme qui ont
été par les gouvernements de l'époque
malmenaient voir oublier en cours de
route donc on voit bien la fragilité du
juridique d'un des comme et il faut
aller pour nous plus loin et surtout
structurer davantage la démarche d'où
cette question de la holding qui a pour
grand avantage de respecter les
structures
existantes qui restent avec leur culture
leur histoire mais aussi leur statut et
leur
mode de rémunération on y reviendra
peut-être tout à l'heure évidemment
entre le rapport gatelin et puis
aujourd'hui un rapport qui préconisait
déjà la holding et puis aujourd'hui
cette PPL il y a eu une autre un autre
texte qui malheureusement n'est pas
arrivé au bout c'était le projet de
loir-ether vous le vous en souvenez qui
avait été présenté par Franck Riester en
2019 et qui s'était arrêté au stade de
la commission des affaires culturelles
de l'Assemblée nationale
nous étions en pleine période de la
covid vous en souvenez les travaux
législatifs ont été interrompus à ce
moment-là la PPL je le dis en toute
franchise s'inspire fortement sur aspect
là en tout cas de cette proposition de
loi s'inspire fortement du du projet de
loir-y Esther qui était porté bien sûr
par le ministre de la culture de
l'époque mais aussi par la majorité
gouvernementale de l'époque qui
est toujours en tout cas majorité
relative aujourd'hui mais qui est
toujours majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale aujourd'hui
deuxième partie de cette proposition de
loi le chapitre 2 qui traite d'un
certain nombre de points pour corriger
les asymétries dont je vous parlais tout
à l'heure alors forcément il y a
différentes asymétries il y a différents
aspects qui sont concernés qui fait que
il peut paraître un côté un petit peu
pêle-mêle dans la présentation que je
vais vous faire mais évidemment chacun a
sa logique d'abord à travers
l'article 10 on essaye enfin on essaie
on s'attaque à la question des droits
sportifs à travers deux dispositifs qui
visent à
favoriser l'accès de tous
aux grands événements sportifs et faire
en sorte que
le sport qui comme je disais tout à
l'heure est quelque chose est un
événement populaire par définition et
par nature soit accessible au plus grand
nombre le la première partie de cet
article 12
visa étendre aux plateformes dont on
sait depuis maintenant plusieurs mois
qu'elles sont fortement intéressées par
l'acquisition des droits de transmission
non seulement fortement intéressés mais
elles sont devenues un acteur du sport
on l'a vu notamment c'était l'année
dernière à Roland Garros avec la fameuse
le fameux match Nadal
Djokovic je me trompe pas j'aurais monté
plus spécialiste que moi encore où on a
bien vu la puissance
d'Amazon pour obtenir la retransmission
de ce match donc c'est devenu des
acteurs majeurs et donc à travers cet
article on impose deux choses
l'obligation faite aux chaînes pardon
l'obligation faite aux plateformes
d'avoir la même obligation qu'on les
chaînes payantes par abonnement de céder
à des services de télévision accessibles
diffusées sur la TNT certains droits
relatifs à des événements sportifs on
est typiquement dans la question de la
symétrie à savoir que les les chaînes
payantes ont des obligations de
rétrocéder une partie des droits
relatifs des événements sportifs les
plateformes n'ont pas cette obligation
donc nous intégrons les plateformes dans
ce système d'obligation et deuxième
aspect sur cet article 10 concernant les
droits de retransmission sportif
qui vise à s'assurer que les diffuseurs
extérieurs à l'Union européenne ne
pourront pas s'approprier plus des deux
tiers des droits de diffusion lors d'un
appel d'offres lancé par une ligue
professionnelle pour l'attribution des
droits de diffusion
là aussi
je rappelle le titre de la pppl c'est la
PPL sur la souveraineté audiovisuelle
vous allez très clairement compris qu'il
s'agissait d'assurer à travers cet
article la souveraineté audiovisuelle
française mais européenne de des acteurs
français ou européens aux droits
sportifs l'article 11
qui est
un article
d'une autre nature et qui concerne un
sujet qui est devenu on le sait depuis
maintenant quelques temps un sujet
majeur
pour l'ensemble des acteurs de
l'audiovisuel public ou privé la
question de la visibilité appropriée
vous le savez les télévisions connectées
font que notre système très protégé
finalement très encadré de la TNT qui
privilégie l'accès à un certain nombre
d'acteurs ceux qui ont tenu obtenu les
autorisations des maîtres de l'arcom ce
système peut éclater avec les
télévisions connectées et le fait que ce
n'est plus une autorité de régulation ce
n'est plus l'utilisateur mais c'est
l'équipementier qui à travers
l'interface va privilégier ou va mettre
en avant tel ou tel diffuseur est une
vraie menace sur l'ensemble des acteurs
français la le réflexe de prendre sa
télécommande et d'appuyer sur le bouton
1 pour accéder à TF1 le bouton 2 je vais
pas vous faire la litanie vous la
connaissez la série mais évidemment avec
la télé vision connectée on change
complètement de paradigme et c'est plus
une logique d'attribution par l'Autorité
de régulation mais c'est une logique il
faut bien la qualifier marchande qui va
privilégier tel ou tel
ou telle diffuseur tel ou tel
chaîne au détriment des autres et il est
évident que dans cette logique marchande
la puissance financière des plateformes
est une vraie menace pour nos acteurs
franco-français dont on sait que la
taille les budgets ne permettent pas de
concurrencer de manière réelle les
plateformes américaines vous l'avez bien
vu si vous avez acheté une télécommande
récemment vous voyez maintenant sur
votre télécommande apparaître un bouton
Netflix
ou Amazon on voit bien que derrière ce
bouton Netflix ou Amazon c'est pas
comment dirais-je une discussion de
salon qui entre le président de Netflix
et
l'équipementier c'est bien sûr une
négociation commerciale qui a eu lieu
avec des sommes qu'on ne connaît pas
mais qui doit être extrêmement
importantes pour assurer la présence la
visibilité des différents acteurs et il
y a une vraie menace à ce que nos
acteurs français soient complètement
dilués voire soit reléguer au second au
troisième temps si la législation ne
n'intervient pas à ce niveau-là et c'est
pour ça que dans l'article 11
on prévoit que les services d'intérêt
général sont constitués par l'ensemble
des services et programmes édités par
les chaînes de la TNT
cet article prévoit également que ces
services et programmes devront être
tétées de la même façon que les services
et les programmes les mieux exposés sur
les interfaces utilisateurs l'idée est
très clairement de dire que quand on
utilisait une télévision connectée et
quand on l'allume on puisse voir au
premier plan les chaînes de la TNT
article 12 j'avance peut-être qu'on aura
besoin de revenir sur ces différents
éléments mais vous le ferez à travers
vos questions article 12 d'un autre
aspect de la loi de
86 aspect dont on a parlé il y a
quelques mois sur un sujet d'actualité à
savoir la question de la durée pendant
laquelle le 2 théorie le détenteur d'une
autorisation des maîtres ne peut pas
revendre
le contrôle de l'entreprise qui édite
les programmes vous le savez
depuis 2016 de mémoire la
durée minimum de 5 ans a été fixé dans
la loi de 86 pour éviter les phénomènes
spéculatifs nous pensons que si il est
nécessaire de maintenir une durée en
revanche le delet de 5 ans et maintenant
disproportionné et que les phénomènes
spéculatifs qu'on a pu craindre qu'on a
vu d'ailleurs et qu'on a pu craindre à
un moment ne sont pas aujourd'hui la
principale menace c'est quand même
relativement limité d'où la proposition
de réduire à deux ans au lieu des 5 ans
cette durée minimale
l'article 13 concerne un autre aspect
qui est la question de là aussi dans la
loi de 86 la définition de la production
en individuelle indépendante et vise à
exclure le régime des mandats de
commercialisation pour inciter les
chaînes à investir davantage dans les
productions de qualité donc vise à
sortir les mandats de commercialisation
des de la loi de 86 quelle est l'idée
qui est derrière c'est une idée qui est
je dois avouer n'est pas innovante ici
au Sénat puisque nous l'avons défendu et
je me tourne vers Jean-Raymond Hugonnet
qui l'a défendu à plusieurs reprises
à travers lors de différents textes ou
législatif ou rapport évidemment nous
sommes tous très attachés au système de
production française nous constatons
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui que la question
principale n'est pas la question du
financement l'apparition des nouveaux
acteurs n'a pas que du mauvais en
l'occurrence les plateformes américaines
participent aussi avec des moyens qui
sont assez
conséquents à au financement de la
production
cinématographique cinématographique ou
audiovisuel tant mieux en revanche il y
a une vraie question qui se pose autour
du partage de la valeur entre les
diffuseurs et les producteurs
ne vous a pas échappé ne nous a pas
échappé que il y a quelques semaines on
parlait d'un rachat possible d'une
chaîne en l'occurrence M6 par un
producteur dans un consortium mais par
un producteur donc on voit bien que
économiquement il y a maintenant une
inversion
des puissances qui s'opèrent et qui
illustrent finalement le fait que pour
les diffuseurs qui financent les
productions du budget les
cinématographiques le
la rentabilité financière si on peut la
qualifier ainsi ou le retour financier
c'est peut-être mieux que rentabilité le
retour financier est insuffisant je
citerai juste un chiffre qui est celui
de France Télévisions je crois que
France Télévisions finance chaque année
460 millions de production
audiovisuel si on rajoute les 60
millions de cinéma on doit être à 520
millions en tout et le revenu tiré en
termes de de droite commercialisation
notamment sont à peine 10 millions
chaque année on a donc une vraie
réflexion dans le partage de la valeur
sur la les les retours sur de en matière
de production
audiovisuelle article 14 je pense qu'on
reviendra sur sur cet aspect là dans
quelques instants il me reste plus que
deux articles sur assurez-vous je vais
bientôt m'arrêter l'article 14 qui sont
deux articles un peu technique mais qui
nous paraissent absolument indispensable
aussi l'article 14
prévoit que les services interactifs
fournis par les chaînes de la TNT
doivent être obligatoirement repris par
les distributeurs cette disposition doit
permettre le déploiement de la norme
HbbTV qui permet de renforcer
l'attractivité de la TNT il y a eu du
dernier texte de loi celui de Roselyne
Bachelot il y avait un certain nombre de
d'incitations sur la HbbTV nous voulons
aller plus loin à travers cet article 14
et enfin article 15
traite de du DAB plus donc de la radio
nous sommes là aussi alertés par les
chaînes de radio qui
nous disent tout l'intérêt l'importance
du DAB plus pour la diffusion de de la
radio
et à travers cet article nous savons que
l'arcome a engagé
une réflexion qui doit aboutir mais pas
avant le début où on va dire le premier
semestre de l'année prochaine sur un
certain nombre de mesures du concernant
le DAB+
pour ne pas attendre encore une année
mais pour
favoriser ce DAB+ nous prévoyons à
travers cet article 15 de mesure
de généraliser
la généralisation de l'obligation pour
les postes de radio de recevoir la
radio numérique terrestre selon la norme
DAB+ vous savez qu'il y a un certain
nombre de
radios qui sont actuellement
commercialisés notamment des radios que
je devrais je sais pas si je peux
utiliser le terme mais je vais le faire
parce que j'en trouve pas d'autres bas
de gamme qui sont commercialisés
actuellement les premiers prix les
premiers prix qui n'intègrent pas la
norme dab plus et puis deuxième élément
dans l'article 15 le fait d'obliger dans
les véhicules neufs pour la question de
l'accès à la radio dans les automobiles
d'obliger dans les véhicules neufs de
recevoir là aussi la radio numérique
terrestre selon la norme dabb dab plus
voilà quelques éléments de enfin non je
crois que je les ai tous dit d'ailleurs
les éléments de de cette PPL vous voyez
que c'est une PPL
qui est dense qui est une PPL comment
dirais-je encore une fois dans un esprit
très constructif qui s'est fait beaucoup
à l'écoute des acteurs et avec une ligne
directrice comment assurer une
souveraineté audiovisuelle
pour nos différents acteurs dans un
paysage qui est un paysage complexe
concurrentiel avec des concurrents qui
ont une puissance financière encore une
fois qui est incomparable à celle de nos
acteurs français il est donc nécessaire
que le législateur intervienne et c'est
dans cet esprit que j'ai déposé cette
PPL sans
anticiper mais je crois pouvoir dire
dans le premier signataire sera
jean-romae
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire dans
le propos introductif vous avez
certainement des questions vous qui êtes
présent ou celles et ceux d'entre vous
qui êtes derrière vos écrans n'hésitez
pas à vous manifester
qui me posait
bonjour Lorient nombreux pour
publicitaire j'ai une question
concernant l'article le premier elle est
à trois de votre PPL qui concerne du
coup la création d'une holding
regroupant France médium France
Télévisions Radio France et Lina quelle
différence faites-vous entre ce projet
de holding et l'ortfoot en 74 merci
c'est pas que je fais des différences je
vois pas de poids communs c'est toute
une toute autre logique permettant avant
de répondre à vos questions je
m'aperçois que j'ai oublié de dire deux
choses qui peuvent être important pour
votre compréhension d'abord il y a un
article qui prévoit de transformer Lina
en société c'est un établissement public
donc en tant qu’établissement public il
ne peut pas rentrer dans un holding donc
il faut d'abord le transformer en
société anonyme et puis deuxième chose
j'ai oublié de le dire mais vous avez
tout de suite comprendre pourquoi Arte
n'est pas concerné par la holding
puisque Arte et régie par une convention
internationale et donc évidemment
l'intérêt
premier que nous partageons tous pour
Arte c'est privilégier la relation
franco-allemande donc il n’intéresse pas
dans
quel est le rapprochement avec l'ORTF
c'est ça sera une structure indépendante
c'est il y a une holding qui réunit les
différents acteurs pour à la fois être
un interlocuteur plus puissant
par rapport à l'État par rapport à Bercy
en particulier mais aussi par rapport
aux différents partenaires privés tout à
l'heure je parlais des équipements
entiers
si l'ensemble de l'audiovisuel public va
discuter avec des équipementsistes ça a
plus de force que si individuellement
ils vont les uns les autres frapper à la
porte par exemple de Sony ou d'autres ou
discuter avec Netflix ou Amazon ça c'est
le premier objectif le 2 le deuxième
objectif
c'est bien sûr de définir une stratégie
nous avons des
personnels dans l'audio public et
notamment au niveau du personnel de
direction qui personnelle de très grande
qualité
d'ailleurs notez que les uns et les
autres ont été
renouvelés récemment c'est la preuve
qu'elles ont et ils ont rempli leur
mission et que c'est des gens de très
grande qualité mais
ils ont besoin d'avoir des orientations
stratégiques de la part de l'État qui
soit plus affirmé plus clair qui soit
moins dans le suivi mais plus dans
l'anticipation on l'a bien vu notamment
sur la question du numérique ou
l'audiovisuel public malgré sa puissance
a réagit très tardivement finalement
celui qui réagi le plus rapidement sur
la question du numérique c'est Arte
alors que français vision et Radio
France c'est pas leur faire un jour que
de dire ça de dire ça on réagi avec un
temps de retard il y a une vraie
réflexion à avoir sur comment dans un
environnement encore une fois je le
redis mais vous l'avez tous à l'esprit
qui est extrêmement mouvant comment dans
un environnement extrêmement mouvant
dans les évolutions sont en cours et ne
sont pas achevées comment l'audiovisuel
public peut agir de manière rapide nous
pensons que
notamment sur les aspects stratégiques
tout à l'heure je vous parlais de la
l'intelligence artificielle je vous
parlais de la télévision connectée
notamment sur ces aspects là la relation
est à
avec les présidentes ou président des
différentes villes publiques compte tenu
de la difficulté de l'État définir une
stratégie est un frein c'est pas du tout
un problème du côté des entités
audiovisuelles c'est un problème du côté
de l'État à définir l'outil la holding a
vraiment vocation à produire
cette stratégie et réfléchir aux
évolutions et se donner les moyens
d'agir ensemble encore une fois ce qu'on
note et personne ne le conteste que ce
soit l'état à travers les orientations
du code que ce soit les
présidentes je pense à celle de Radio
France ou de France Télévisions à
travers la note stratégique qu'elles ont
cosigné dans le cadre de la libération
du futur com tout le monde
converge pour envers l'idée de dire il
faut davantage travailler ensemble c'est
l'esprit de cette ligne travailler
ensemble ne veut pas dire contrôler le
contenu bien entendu que non et c'est
pour ça que je ne fais pas de parallèle
loin sans faute plus à cette époque avec
l'ORTF
bonjour Fabio Benedetti pour les échos
j'aurais deux questions la première sur
le duel public donc vous dites vouloir
donc créer un interlocuteur encore plus
puissant pour vis-à-vis des plateformes
et de tous les intervenants sur le
marché
pourquoi ne pas avoir laissé donc à
l'arcome en fait la décision de nominés
voilà de désigner donc le président de
cette holding pour que voilà pour
garantir donc pour garantir
l'indépendance et puis la deuxième
question c'est sur le donc l'action de
la commercialisation des droits et c'est
à dire que vous voulez un
assouplissement de la des interdictions
de d'intégration verticale et donc où
poser le curseur comment concrètement
faire en sorte que qu'il y a plus de
revenus en fait pour les pour les
coupures du visuels est-ce que est-ce
que les quotas donc de production
dépendante notamment on doit être revu
voilà par quoi ça passerait donc
concrètement cette cette assouplissement
et est-ce que véritablement vous voulez
l'assouplissement ou même une remise en
question plus profonde de la de la
désinterdictions qui limite aujourd'hui
l'intégration verticale entre diffuseur
et producteur
alors sur la nomination du du Président
nous avons prévu un processus de
nomination qui en fait
associe le plus grand nombre d'abord
l'initiative vient du conseil
d'administration c'est le conseil
d'administration de la structure qui
propose
un ou plusieurs candidats
pour la présidence la nomination se fait
par un décret au Conseil des ministres
comme c'est le cas d'ailleurs
actuellement et avant cette ce décret en
Conseil des ministres il y a deux
consultations avec aviconfort celui de
l'arcom donc l'arcome est bien acteur
essentiel du processus de domination et
celui des deux commissions
concernées à l'Assemblée nationale et au
Sénat donc il y a finalement c'est par
rapport à votre question sur
l'indépendance le fait d'associer le
plus grand nombre si on regarde le
paysage actuel des différentes
compositions vous voyez que ça assure
entre les deux chambres l'arcom le
décret en Conseil des ministres et la
proposition du conseil d'administration
avec un conseil d'administration vous
avez noté que la composition ition est
assez ouverte ça assure une indépendance
nous semble-t-il pour le futur président
et surtout un consensus sur la
désignation
sur votre deuxième sujet qui est la
question de
des
droits sur les la production je serai
peut-être j'aurais mon complété aussi
s'il veut sur ce point bon c'est un
sujet sur lequel nous nous avons
beaucoup travaillé depuis de nombreuses
années encore une fois je le redis mais
on avait proposé un certain nombre
d'amendements
visant à rééquilibrer le partage de la
valeur encore une fois je fais vraiment
la distinction entre la question du
financement de la production
indépendante qui nous paraît essentielle
et sur lequel nous ne souhaitons pas
intervenir parce qu'ils nous paraît
pertinent enfin le système actuel nous
paraît pertinent en revanche c'est sur
la question du partage de la valeur des
revenus tirés de cette production entre
les diffuseurs et les producteurs ce
partage nous paraît déséquilibré
actuellement
et il y a comme dans tout système
notamment pour assurer le financement
des des diffuseurs il faut aussi assurer
des ressources qui soient autre que les
ressources publiques traditionnelles
sachant que nous tenons je le redis
évidemment à ce que l'audiovisuel public
notamment n'est pas accès
pour ce qui est France Télévisions aux
ressources publicitaires ou de manière
très marginale donc il faut aussi
assurer des revenus et nous pensons que
la question de du partage de la valeur
est actuellement déséquilibrée entre
entre les diffuseurs et les producteurs
d'où l'idée on ne remet pas en question
alors il n'y a pas de remise en question
des quotas dans notre dans ma PPL
dans les aspects qui sont dans la loi de
86 je crois qu'il y a cinq il y a cinq
règles qui définissent la production
indépendante et qui
assure le financement de la de la
production indépendante n'en touchant
qu'un celui sur les droits de
commercialisation pour permettre à ce
que
lorsqu'un acteur de l'audiovisuel
finance une production il y a une
négociation
sur les droites commercialisation entre
le producteur et l'éditeur ce qu'on
constate c'est que cette nuggi session
elle existe avec les plateformes
on a du mal du reste à savoir comment
cette négociation entre une plateforme
et un producteur indépendant se fait et
ce qui est une vraie négociation est-ce
que c'est des règles qui sont imposées
par les plateformes mais en tout cas là
clairement on est sur une asymétrie de
concurrence entre les chaînes françaises
et les plateformes et les chaînes
françaises se voient imposer des règles
que non pas les plateformes et donc
c'est pour ça que nous remettons en fait
en négociation commerciale cet aspect
des droits de commercialisation je sais
pas
dans votre question c'était induit il
s'agit plus d'une souplesse le président
Laffont l'a dit c'est un des critères
qui est ici discuté moi ce que je
n'oublie pas et c'est peut-être l'élu
local avant d'être parlementaire qui qui
veut ça c'est que tout cela est financé
quand on parle d'audiovisuel public
c'est financé comment
c'est financer avec de l'argent public
et l'argent public dans ce lieu
républicain voilà c'est sacré
et est-ce que l'argent public a vocation
a financer
vous voyez ce que je veux dire des
retours Laurent Lafont l'a dit tout à
l'heure entre 460 millions d'euros si on
considère pas le cinéma c'est 60
millions de cinéma 520 millions d'euros
avec un résultat de 10 millions d'euros
ce n'est pas être capitaliste de dire ça
c'est être responsable de l'argent
public
peut-être qu'on peut ouvrir la porte
parce que je sais pas vous mais moi je
commence à avoir un peu chaud
aussi
qu'allez-vous répondre ou en tout cas
est-ce que vous avez mis en place des
garde-fous ou de des de la sécurité en
fait pour les acteurs qui auraient peur
de la holding je pense à France media
Mons notamment qui ont peur d'être
dilués dans un ensemble d'être moins la
priorité voilà dans un ensemble plus
fort deuxième question vous avez pas du
tout parler de financement et des
modalités de financement de la holding
et ce qu'il y a des choses qui sont
prévues dans le texte et vous avez pas
non plus parlé de concentration alors
vous avez quand même beaucoup travaillé
sur le sujet
alors bon par rapport à la peur que que
peut générer la création de la holding
par rapport à aux structures qui en sont
membres pardon qui en seront membres
évidemment nous ne
désistait pas c'est ces phénomènes
de peur qui sont
évidemment liés à toutes évolution
et bien sûr il faut arriver à y répondre
c'est notamment dans dans
je vais revenir dans un instant comment
on essaie d'y répondre ce que je
voudrais dire c'est que le phénomène de
dilution il existe déjà holding ou
paolding c'est à dire que si tu es
France médiamonde qui fait un excellent
travail et que nous soutenons beaucoup
ici France media monde avec son budget
dont on sait qu'il est limité
par rapport surtout dans un
schéma international dans lequel agit
France mediamonde France médiévonde s'il
n'est pas davantage protégé davantage
soutenu et c'est bien l'objectif de la
holding France médias vivante est
évidemment fragilisée
donc je comprends la peur d'être
dilué mais
la crainte ou le risque principal c'est
pas celui-là le risque principal c'est
d'être trop petit par rapport à des trop
gros
sur la question de l'audio elles sont
maintenues on sait que ces structures
qui sont des structures anciennes qui
ont une histoire une culture des statues
différents fait que le personnel de ces
structures sont attachées
à ce qui constitue leur histoire comme
leur présent
le schéma de la holding le scénario de
la holding permet de préserver ces
identités permet de préserver justement
ce qui fait la richesse de chacune de
ces structures il y avait un deuxième
niveau qui était d'aller plus loin dans
la fusion
en fusionnant par exemple les réseaux de
de France 3 et France Bleu au niveau
local pour accentuer la nécessité des
rapprochements au niveau local et puis
il y avait le troisième niveau celui de
la fusion totale de l'ensemble des
structures qui a été notamment
préconisée l'année dernière ici même
parce que ça me paraissait aller dans le
bon sens vous avez noté que
à travers la PPL nous mettons en place
uniquement le premier niveau c'est à
dire la holdi c'est une réponse me
semble-t-il à aux craintes éventuelle
que peut générer un rapprochement se
rapprochement il est inévitable
encore une fois c'est pas uniquement
nous qui le disons nous nous le portons
depuis 2015 nous l'un et l'autre
sénateur en 2015 mais nos prédécesseurs
le porter depuis 2015 mais ce diagnostic
de 2015 il a été partagé dans le com de
2022 chez book 2018-2022 et il sera
aussi dans le comme à venir qui sera
signé d'ici la fin de l'année donc c'est
un la nécessité de se rapprocher est une
nécessité qui est partagée je crois
maintenant par tous
alors sur votre deuxième question sur le
financement de la holding vous avez tout
à fait raison nous n'avons rien dit sur
le financement ou avant juste ajouter
une petite phrase qui n'est pas sans
importance de dire que le financement
doit être pérenne de nature fiscale et
qu'il doit prendre en compte l'inflation
c'est pas totalement innocent je dois
vous avouer notamment la deuxième partie
de ce que je viens de vous dire enfin la
première comme la deuxième le fait que
ce soit pérenne et de nature fiscale
c'est très clairement une orientation
tout à l'heure je vous disais que nous
sommes dans un schéma de co-construction
et que
l'État devra faire des propositions
concernant le financement puisque on
sait que le schéma qui a été mis en
oeuvre dans la loi de finances
rectificative de doute dernier
supprimant la contribution prévoit une
attribution d'une fraction de TVA un
système jusqu'en 2024 compris il
s'achève en 2025 et que les études
juridiques qui ont été réalisées
montrent que si on veut pérenniser
au-delà de 2024 le système de fraction
de TVA il faudra modifier la Golf
la Golf est une loi organique qui
suppose donc une majorité qualifiée au
niveau des deux chambres et donc un
accord du Sénat et donc
oups et donc
et donc la question du financement sera
abordée à cette question à travers à ce
moment là
sur proposition du gouvernement je
précise la phrase exacte qu'on a
introduit parce que je vous en ai dit
qu'une partie sur le financement la
principale chose de financement des
sociétés est constituée par une rupture
publique de nature fiscale pérenne
suffisante prévisible et en prenant en
compte l'inflation
ça exclut une piste très clairement que
personne ne souhaite qui est celle de la
subvention
puisque nous souhaitons que ça soit de
nature fiscale je dis personne ne
souhaite parce que vous savez que sur la
suppression de la contribution tout le
monde n'était pas d'accord je le dis
d'autant plus en me tournant envers
la suppression je ne l'ai pas voté mais
par contre une chose sur lequel je crois
nous nous retrouvons tous ici au Sénat
comme nos collègues députés sur le fait
de dire que il faut un financement de
nature fiscale
sur la concentration sur la
concentration c'est un autre sujet voilà
cette PPL n'est pas une PPL j'allais
dire fourre-tout dans lequel on embrasse
tous les sujets qui concernent le devis
visuel il y a une cohérence qui est la
cohérence de
la symétrie de cette préservation d'une
souveraineté enfin de la lutte contre
les assumes symétries de préservation de
d'une souveraineté audiovisuelle et donc
la question de la concentration est un
sujet d'une autre nature et donc qui
n'est pas abordé clairement dans ce
texte
oui juste rajouter peut-être une chose
parce que là aussi les mots leur
importance vous avez commencé votre
question par la peur
alors déjà la peur est mauvaise
conseillère ça c'est la première des
choses mais pensez-vous qu'il soit
aujourd'hui question de peur la peur
c'est d'avoir une loi qui date de 86 qui
a été rafistolé à plus de 80 reprises et
qui tient un milieu qui est en
changement perpétuel avec avec des une
rapidité dans l'évolution donc c'est ça
moi qui me fait peur c'est pas le fait
de parce que encore une fois la holding
vous voyez ce que je veux dire tu
Laurent Lafont en parler tout à l'heure
nous avons produit un rapport
préconisant la fusion et je suis certain
qu'elle viendra dans combien de temps je
peux pas vous le dire mais je suis
certain qu'elle viendra parce que c'est
le sens de l'histoire aujourd'hui c'est
la holding on ne doit pas en avoir peur
et pour faire très court vous parlez
dans votre deuxième question de France
média monde il ne vous aura pas échappé
que j'en suis membre du conseil
d'administration pensez-vous
qu'aujourd'hui les conditions qui sont
faites à France médiamonde sont les
meilleurs pour en faire un outil
remarquable et si on renverse le Para
digme qui ne coûte pas très cher au
moment où la géopolitique est un sujet
majeur et bien moi je pense que la
holding va lui donner de la puissance en
tout cas en tant que manque de conseil
d'administration j'y vais soyez sûr
il y a une question
allez-y quelqu'un derrière son écran
c'est qui Margot Delpierre
madame Dassonville
nous on nous entend pas par contre
cette salle est nouvelle vous la
connaissez peut-être pas
ils peuvent le peut-être par écrit la
poser
monsieur bricela aime le
bonjour l'un des objectifs de la holding
est-il aussi de mutualiser les fonctions
non éditoriales comme la régie
publicitaire la formation ou la
recherche et développement
ça sera la ligne de définir nous nous
pensons effectivement que sur un certain
nombre de fonctions supports il y a des
rapprochements possibles vous vous avez
cité par exemple la question de la
formation on sait que Lina a un pôle
formation qui est extrêmement performant
depuis au moins deux comme on nous dit
il faut davantage recourir à cette à la
formation faite par Lina et à la
structure de formation de de Lina on
voit bien que ça avance très très
lentement enfin télévision inclus un
accord je crois qu'il y aura duo France
est en train d'en concurrence si je me
trompe pas mais enfin ça avancerait
lentement typiquement sur ce sujet là de
la formation oui la holding doit être un
accélérateur
puissant pour agir davantage j'ai pas
noté les deux autres éléments qui
étaient à part la formation il y avait
la formation la régie publicitaire et la
recherche est développement oui
typiquement aussi et notamment sur la
recherche et développement je parlais
dans les axes stratégiques de
l'intelligence artificielle
le numérique qui est encore un axe
stratégique bien entendu les télévisions
connectées c'était évident que plutôt
que de réfléchir chacun de son côté
plutôt que de mettre des moyens
financiers chacun de son côté avec des
effets redondants
il y aura beaucoup plus de performances
et d'effets de levier sur ces sur ces
sujets là agir ensemble à travers la
holding
et la deuxième question du monde donc de
Aude d'Assonville pourquoi relancer
aujourd'hui un projet de holding que le
ministère de la Culture ne semble pas à
ce stade en tout cas porter
d'abord on attend la réponse du
ministère de la Culture
je ne sais pas ce qu'ils vont penser de
la ligne nous verrons bien mais encore
une fois je crois que le temps politique
fait que le dialogue doit s'établir en
rassemblée nationale Sénat et
gouvernement que ce soit sur la question
du financement de la Golf modification
de la Golf et de la pérennisation du
système de TVA que ce soit sur la
question des missions de service public
puisque nos collègues députés y
travaillent ou que ce soit nous à
travers cette PPL donc je pense que
c'est du débat de de l'échange que nous
définirons ensemble
cette future organisation de levisuel
et le Sénat à travers cette PPL apporte
encore une fois sa pierre à l'édifice et
nous disons ce que nous voulons en tout
cas du côté de la majorité sénatoriale
et bien sûr on va être très attentif
à ce que peuvent dire que ce soit à
travers l'ambition d'information mais de
manière plus générale nos collègues
députés nos collègues de la commission
ça fait culturelle de l'Assemblée
nationale et bien sûr ce que peut dire
la ministre sur ces sujets là le
dialogue ne se crée pas aujourd'hui il y
a des il y a des échanges depuis
plusieurs mois avec la ministre
notamment
ce que nous annonçons là n'est pas une
surprise
encore une fois c'est une position très
ancienne du Sénat une date de 2015 c'est
pas une surprise elle nous paraît
d'autant plus nécessaire aujourd'hui
voilà et le fait que
le précédent gouvernement en 2019 avait
porté finalement sur la partie holding
pas sur les asymétries mais sur la
partie holding un projet de réforme
similaire doit avouer encore une fois
que nous sommes assez proches du projet
de loiri Esther sur la partie holding
fait que ce que nous disons aujourd'hui
doit pas être très très éloigné de ce
que pense la majorité gouvernementale
enfin j'imagine
peut-être l'occasion d'aider justement
madame la ministre à être parti prenante
dans ce sujet parce que comme bien de le
dire Laurent Laffont en termes vraiment
spécifiquement de la holding c'est une
reprise aussi de ce que Franck Riester
avait porté et donc il y avait été
validé par la commission culture de
l'Assemblée nationale certes sur le
processeur en quinquennat mais on n'est
pas là dans une révolution croyez moi
mais on est là dans une vraiment une PPL
qui fait oeuvre utile car c'est
l'ensemble de l'écosystème qui réclame
une évolution
Madame Véronique Martinat et est-ce que
la PPL va être inscrite très
prochainement à l'ordre du jour du Sénat
oui elle se elle doit être inscrite
normalement la semaine du 12 juin
donc c'est assez rapide effectivement
oui bonjour Myriam Lemaire la radio
fréquence protective
la création de la holding au fond va
aboutir à créer une structure
supplémentaire
comment la
dimensionnez-vous est-ce que parce que
pour éviter un surcoût trop important
qui une nouvelle structure s'ajoutant
alors dans notre esprit c'est une
structure légère c'est une structure
d'une vingtaine de personnes
compte tenu de la taille et du nombre de
des différentes structures qu'il la
composent la personne c'est quelque
chose de léger et financièrement assez
facile à absorber c'est une structure en
plus qui va remplir des missions qui
sont partiellement assurés déjà je pense
côté des gcmix par exemple sur la
répartition des financements entre les
différentes entités ou dans les
différentes structures qui composeront
la holding par des personnels de
direction donc on peut très bien
imaginer que les personnels de la
holding c'est pas à nous de d'aller
jusqu'à ce niveau de détails ce sera aux
acteurs même de les finir mais que les
personnels de la holding soient composés
d'un certain nombre de personnes qui
sont déjà en fonction dans ces
différents entités
oui Florian Krieg le film français vous
parliez d'une discussion tripartite
entre le gouvernement le Sénat et
l'Assemblée nationale il y a un
quatrième acteur qui pourrait intervenir
c'est la Commission européenne notamment
sur les deux tiers des d'un appel
d'offres qui ne peuvent pas être détenus
par un diffuseur en dehors de l'Union
Européenne est-ce que vous avez des
garanties à ce niveau déjà
pas encore nos premières approches nous
font penser que la rédaction peut
rentrer effectivement dans le cadre de
la législation européenne c'est pour ça
qu'on l'a mis avec on aurait pu aller en
dessous des deux tiers
on a même réfléchi pour tout vous dire
elle est plus loin que les deux tiers et
ABC à la moitié mais justement pour
entrer dans les clous de la législation
européenne on en reste au niveau des
deux tiers
j'ai parlé d'un dialogue tripartite il y
a bien sûr une quatrième série d'acteurs
c'est les dirigeants de l'audiovisuel
public mais c'était évident donc je l'ai
pas dit de nouveau mais évidemment il y
a un dialogue aussi avoir avec les les
personnes qui dirigent chez différentes
entités évidemment
dialogue qui existe déjà en train de
vous le dire mais évidemment nous sommes
en contact régulier et fréquent avec
justement ce que vous proposez pour
remplacer le mot 5 par 2 ans pour
permettre à un acteur de revendre un
groupe c'est pour permettre à RTL Group
de revendre M6 dans deux ans vous avez
intégré cette disposition évidemment
tout le monde pense à M6 puisque on sait
que M6 était vendeur enfin un
comportement était vendeur il y a
quelques mois que son préjugés de de
leur stratégie on peut imaginer qu'il
soit de nouveau vendeurs donc on pense
on peut penser M6 mais ça ne se limite
pas M6 c'est c'est plus une souplesse
supplémentaire qui est donnée encore une
fois on ne supprime pas totalement la
mesure
on laisse un délai minimal en
l'occurrence deux ans on supprime pas
totalement la mesure mais on l'assouplit
parce que cinq ans du point de vue
économique c'est un temps qui est très
long voilà et qui fige les choses
c'était d'ailleurs un peu l'optique au
moment où cette enfin cette modification
de la loi de 86 a été passée c'était de
figé les choses dans le temps là il nous
semble que ce n'est pas raisonnable
compte tenu d'une réorganisation
possible du secteur de mettre un délai
si long
ça ça peut concerner M6 mais ça peut
concerner d'autres acteurs également
est-ce qu'il y a non il y a plus de
questions derrière les écrans
la salle non plus
bien mais nous revient maintenant vous
remercier de votre écoute et puis bien
sûr on se tient à votre disposition si
vous voulez poursuivre ces échanges
merci à tous